- [Narrator] Maps from all over the world
can be found at the click of a button,
but sometimes places that look blank
are actually full of life.
(soft music)
This is Primož.
And this is Isaac.
Primož and his company Spatial Collective
work with community organizers like Isaac
to map unmapped communities.
- [Narrator] Unmapped
communities are literally
not found on maps.
Important things like roads, schools
and hospitals are missing.
When communities are unmapped,
governments can easily overlook them.
This means that they miss
out on vital resources
that they should have access to.
- [Narrator] The process
begins with members
of the community gathering
information on foot.
These data points are
then sent to the team
at Spatial Collective.
They plot them and fill in the map.
When citizens have information
about what they're missing,
they have the power to
advocate for what they deserve.
(soft tone)